歡迎收看 理財達林秀最受歡迎的教學單元
標古在線等
最近大家知道趙華要講什麼
詐騙太多了 而且會偷我們的影片去偷廣告
所以達林秀這邊呢 給大家一些分辨的方法
第一個 我們沒有投任何的贊助廣告
你看到影片 是我跟朱老師沒有錯
可是下面如果有廣告字眼 有贊助字眼
不管是不是掛我的名字哦
都是詐騙哦 這第一個
第二個呢 沒有錯
達人秀有榮耀班 大家都知道
現在榮耀班也被那些
詐騙的人拿去仿冒 那怎麼辦呢
好 你要到理財達人秀的官網哦
就算你在官網看我們這支教學影片一樣
我們每一支影片裡面
都附有榮耀班的訂閱連結
不會有人叫你加賴群組
點了訂閱連結
也是在YouTube上完成每個月
300元的訂閱
沒有別的了
不會叫你虧錢
不會叫你加LINE
不會騙你
帶鏡帶出哦
所以呢
榮耀班的課程真的很值得
但是不要被騙哦
好
那今天朱老師要來教大家什麼呢
大家都要買股票最怕什麼
最怕跑進去盤整區哦
盤整區有一個問題哦
一火而戰上
一火而跌破
跌破一火而戰上
你覺得在兩面八
完全不討好
洩露盤整區該怎麼判斷
但是最重要的來囉
他如果突破盤整區
不管向上向下
都可能有很大的行情
抓住這個才重要
好 朱老師
我們這個宣導詐騙
每一集都宣導
還是很多人傳訊息說分不清楚
對
詐騙現在太猖獗了
現在也沒有什麼銷向權了
我看每天都被拉去用
我們這樣拍的影片
我記得我們有一集在交比較短線交易的
那個詐騙超級愛
對啊
後來再也不敢交了
現在就說希望大家自己提高警覺
因為詐騙實在太多
而且各種形式的 各種花樣的
因為大家他就利用一小賺錢
應該說不勞而獲的賺錢
我們還是多求證一下比較好
就你覺得好像有點懷疑或怎麼樣
其實問一下朋友
周遭的朋友應該每個人都知道
很多詐騙
像我們官方頻道
都已經70幾萬訂閱了
當然就不會是詐騙
到官方頻道來問
到官方官網上比較安全
今天給大家討論一下盤整
盤整大家都知道很討厭
很難操作
其實我們要認清什麼叫盤整
當你知道它是盤整了
那你就不要操作
因為你知道在盤整區裡面
就是上上下下
但是什麼叫做盤整呢
我們的趨勢
在技術分析來講
趨勢只有三個
一個叫走多頭
一個叫走空頭
一個叫盤整
那劃一句話講
你用想的也知道
盤整就是橫的對不對
走多頭就往上
走空頭就往下
那盤整就是
你一看就是橫的在走
對 那就是盤整
所以我們如果用技術分析的
這個數與來講的話
就不符合多頭
不符合空頭就叫盤整
因為你只有三個
那兩個都不四就是盤存
那什麼叫多頭
我們這個課程都講過很多次
大家都可以來看
那如果他不是頭頭高 底底高
那也不是頭頭低 底底低
那他就是一個盤存
我們下面這三張圖
各位來看一下
那這個頭跟這個頭是水平的
所以他沒有頭頭高
水平的就是這個平行的
那當然它也沒有頭頭低
因為它是平的
那下面也是水平的
那所以你上下兩個
看起來就是一個平行線
那股價當然
你就會看在中間跑嘛
對不對 就橫著走
它沒有往上衝
也沒有下去
那這個就是一個盤整
那一般我們說
這個就叫舉行的盤整
那第二種這個是最常看到
叫三角收裂
也就是說它也不漲
但它也不下去
所以它是頭頭低
底底高
他底底高應該是多啊
可是他沒有頭頭高
那頭頭低應該是空啊
可是他又沒有底底底
所以他就是一個盤枕
那這個就比較特殊
這個屬於喇叭型
喇叭型是有頭頭高
但是下面是底底低
他是底底底
所以他就呈現一個喇叭型的盤枕
好我們先知道了
這個叫盤枕
那實際上盤枕他是有一個順序的
其實不管是多不管是空
不管是盤枕
他的行程都不會一天
不可能一根K線就行程一個趨勢
所以他怎麼行程的
我們先去了解
大家就比較容易去研判這個盤子
怎麼行程盤整
對 這個盤整怎麼行程
假設你現在在做多 很高興
回後買上漲
你是不是就過錢高你就賺錢了
然後回後買上漲
結果這一次沒有過錢高
那沒有過錢高就跌了
但你是不是發現了一個頭頭低了
那我多頭是要頭頭高
你會發現我做多已經改變了
我多頭裡面頭頭高變了
變成頭頭低了
所以這個地方
這個位置我們就叫進入盤枕
你已經開始了
進到盤枕來了
但這個盤枕還沒有確認
為什麼沒有確認
因為這個頭頭低
有可能一直疊一直疊
把它疊成空頭
變成也滴滴滴啦
所以它也不是盤枕啦
它就變空頭了
所以我們知道現在進到盤整
那什麼時候才確認呢
前面的低點沒有跌破
這個時候就有一個轉折的紅K上漲
你就確認有個低點
那你發現我下面還是底底高
沒有改變
只是我上面的頭頭高改了
改成頭頭低
所以這個地方叫確認盤整
這是我確認
因為你確認了盤整
你就要做一件事情
上面的頭頭D 你就畫一個上頸線
就連一條線
頭頭D 這兩個高點把它連一條線
那我下面也確認底底高
那我也連一條線
那這個叫下頸線 這個叫上頸線
當我確認的時候
我就知道我的盤人在什麼範圍裡面
就在這兩條線範圍裡面盤著
那總有一天會出來
要不然這支股票就沒得完
它就永遠這樣橫的
不過有的人真的很很久
對 不過那個大部分都在底部
底部會比較久
一般來說在頭部就不太容易了
在中間大概也不會盤很久
這是一個多頭你做出來的結果
就是說我在做多
所以我們做多一直跟大家講
你要小心不要有頭頭低的現象發生
發生的話雖然不一定變空
但至少你短期就不太容易賺到錢
也就不是多頭了
就是震盪了嘛
他就在震盪了
那如果他原來是空頭會不會改變
當然也會
空頭也不會一直空嘛
一直空就到下勢去了對不對
那空頭只有一天
你去做空的時候
發現前面的低點沒有跌破
那沒有跌破就出現底底高
因為空頭要底底低嘛
那我本來就是頭頭低啊
底底低啊
結果我怎麼會出現一個底底高呢
那就是進到盤整
前面的空頭進到盤整
那你做空的也是要退出來
這邊做多的進到盤整
你也先退出來
讓他去盤
那第二個
他這個底底高之後
在上漲又沒有過前高
就是也沒有出現頭頭高
那這時候就確認盤整
那盤整一樣
你把上景線畫好
下景線換號
那這時候你就很清楚知道
你的股價在哪個範圍裡面盤整
那實際上盤整對我們來說
是一個剛才這個趙娃講的
是一個賺錢的機會
賺錢的機會
因為你盤整到後面
不是往上就往下
那我能不能賺這個區間呢
既然我現化好了
這個區間你要賺就是
上面壓力 下面支撐
我就賺這個
賺價差
但這個呢
一般的盤整都沒有什麼價差
不要忘了你還要手續費啊
還要稅金啊
而且你確認他跌下來空
他又一根黑K啊
然後你確認他不跌了
又一根紅K啊
所以中間的價差基本上來說
是不適合我們去操作
很難賺啦
因為這個叫做資金的效率
你在這裡兩個禮拜上啊
下啊上啊下賺了個半天
結果也賺不到什麼錢
所以我們一般是不鼓勵做盤整
但是這種股票確保
這種股票卻鼓勵你擺在邊上
等著看
對 你就等著他看
讓他去盤嘛
總有人會把他拉出來
或者把他塞下去
對不對
我們就在旁邊等
其實這種才是我們做股票
正確的態度
最期待突破的那一刻
對 我們做股票正確的態度
就是等
等那個關鍵位置
等關鍵位置
對 我們一直跟他講
漲高了不要去追嘛
那你怎麼辦
就等他回來嘛
好 那現在我們就來看一個往下的表態
這個表態剛才有講兩個位置
一個是前面是多嘛 多頭嘛
然後是不是頭頭低進到盤整了
後來又確認盤整了
結果我等了一個最後的結果
居然跌破 把盤整跌破
那盤整跌破是什麼條件呢
就是收盤 要收盤
很多人都在問
朱老師看收盤前10分鐘對不對
大致上要確認
你看我們最近的盤都是開高
慢慢又跌下來
所以你沒有辦法用開盤
最後就可以確認
當你確認他收盤
把下頸線跌破
因為你前面確認的時候
你不是畫了一條下頸線嗎
那這個下頸線就是這兩個
低點的最低點的連線
包括下影線
包括下影線喔
這個也好多人問
所以上下影線都算
包括下引線的最低點
下引線的最低點
然後你連起來一條線
好
但是跌破是收盤
而不是下引線
要收盤跌破
好 要收盤確認
收盤確認 那這個就跌破了
好 那現在我們來看
因為你前面是多頭
我在做多
那這個地方跌破就反轉
這叫反轉確認
所以如果是多頭的盤整跌破
它就轉成空頭了
因為你本來這邊就頭頭低啊
那你現在又把它跌破
你就出現底底底了
它就變空頭了
所以這叫反轉
換句話說你趨勢都改了
你要不要做
這個地方可以考慮開始做空了
做空的機會
對 但是另外一種情形卻不是
前面是空頭
然後底底高了就進到盤枕了
然後又沒有過高
這邊就三角收斂的盤枕
可是它也是跌破
但這個地方的跌破
因為你前面是空頭 所以這個叫敘事
它是沿著前面的趨勢在做的
當然就做空
所以這段就繼續做空
所以一個盤子的疊破
你要去看前面趨勢還有位置
然後你去看它是反轉還是一個敘事
那這時候大概你就可以決定
你要怎麼操作了
因為這個反轉的空頭
在其他的條件
如果還沒有完成的話
有可能你還不能空
什麼條件就是均線
例如說越線要不要下彎
因為你前面是多嘛
所以均線還在往上跑
可是我已經盤整跌破了
可是均線有可能還沒有彎
還在強勢支撐
所以這個就要考慮
不一定就可以空
但這個就不用考慮了
因為你這個本來就是空頭
均線本來就是彎的
那你盤整一跌破
很快的就可以去做空
所以這叫盤整的跌破
好 周老師再跟您確認
你說畫這個上下的線的時候
上下引線都要算進去
可是確認有沒有跌破或站上的話
是實體可以幫
收盤價 對不對
收盤價
那收盤價有的時候
有可能你是跳空啊
對
一開盤就跳空了
那跳空的話
可是你要看你怎麼收
如果你收的有可能是
開低走高的紅K
可是你紅K開低走高
又拉到這個下頸線的裡面
上面那就是還沒有跌破
你是紅K你的收盤在上面
總之看收盤加是
讓你還是沒跌破
那我們就看收盤價就很好了
就反正我們技術分析
就是一個很客觀的東西
有沒有跌破
就是有就有沒有就沒有
沒有就沒有
好那我們來看幾個圖例
我相信你就
這個是向下起跌的圖利
對
那我們來看一下
這個股票在前面是多頭回檔
對不對 回檔沒有跌破前低
他又站上月線
回後買上漲
結果我買了以後
結果黑黑怎麼又跌破五均了
你就發現頭頭低了
我這個高點沒過
好 高點過不了
高點低點都是看上下影線
所以我的高點沒過
糟糕了 我股票進到盤人了
那我就先退出來
那你在這裡買 在這裡退
沒有賺到錢
也沒賠一些
那我就等
那我還沒有確認
怎麼樣確認
這個低點也沒破
對不對
這時候我就畫兩個低點
兩個高點
那這個圖很容易看
兩個高點是上銀線
兩個低點是下銀線
畫起來
畫起來以後
你就會發現後面
正啊 正啊 正啊 正啊 最後是什麼
疊破
這個疊破叫反轉
因為這個是多嘛
這是多頭嘛
那現在變空了嘛
所以這個叫反轉
那當然你要做空
可不可以你就看
月線有沒有疊破
月線有沒有下彎
而且還真的有
下彎了
真的有 它就可以下疊了
這樣對吧
所以我們只要一進到盤整
這個地方進到盤整
你就可以畫了
就開始畫線
所以我們這個做股票
尤其是用技術分析的
畫線 畫這些支撐壓力
是非常重要的
因為你現一畫
你今天就知道跌破了
可是你如果沒有畫
你可能用看的看不出來
是 你不太容易看出來
有沒有跌破
所以用畫的
畫的就很明瞭
那你剛才是不是沒有賺錢
就退出來了
那你後面確認做空
你就賺到了 就賺錢
好 那這也是一樣
這前面是一個
剛才是多 現在前面是空
那空頭反彈 我又坐空
那我坐空這一次
怎麼沒有跌破就站上五軍了
所以我這個空擔就先補了
回補
這一次是有賺到一點
那這時候就進到盤整
那進到盤整 我當然為什麼要退
萬一你一直彈
不是過前高就變多了
所以我就先退
退了以後發現
你還是沒有過前高
你又跌了
那這時候是頭頭低 底底高
我就畫了兩條線 對不對
花瀾的條線你就去等
像這個你看 你等
你在這個頭頭低的底底高你就補了
結果你等大概等了接近三個禮拜
盤了三個禮拜
三個禮拜你可以做別的股票
可以賺錢的
資金效率的問題
那也沒關係 你就等它盤整跌破
那這個跌破你就直接空了
因為它本來就空頭
而且你看一跌破是不是均線
均線全數下彎
你就空
然後後面你就開始做空
那這個就叫做敘事
叫敘事做空頭的敘事
好 大家聽了以後
我相信應該是蠻清楚的
但是以人類操作的習慣來說
一定想要知道的是多頭突破對不對
突破盤整區向上噴一波
那這個會在哪呢
這個會在我們的榮耀班
好 詐騙集團不要來抄我們的影片
到我們的影片
要訂閱榮耀班的話
我們每一支官方頻道下的影片
都有連結 點進去
它會引導你做訂閱
不會有賴群組
不會有人叫你一萬會錢
刷卡 訂閱
一個月只要三百元
非常超級喔
好 接下來我們就要在榮耀班裡面教你囉
什麼叫做突破的多頭區